auf dem grill liegt wieder das was in
einem fischrestaurant auf den gehört
wochenlang musste restaurantbesitzer
oder improvisieren weil den wenigen
gästen die noch kamen der appetit auf
fisch vergangen war er setzte auf
fleisch gebe das hat ihn gerettet über
die zeit im sommer als die prinzeninseln
vor istanbul in einer 10 stinkenden
masse versanken als eine meeres schleim
plage die touristen vertrieb und ihm das
geschäft verdarb
die krise dauerte einen monat und 20
tage das hat alle in der region
betroffen nicht nur uns die besucher
bekamen angst sie wollten keinen fisch
mehr essen
wir sprachen mit ihren aber sie wollten
nicht hören
was ist das für ein schreiben haben sie
gefragt was ist das für eine krankheit
wie sehr wird es uns betreffen
die stadtverwaltung schickte schwimmende
müllschlucker und ließ den schleim
abschöpfen für die tourismuswirtschaft
um das marmarameer war die algenplage
eine katastrophe
jetzt sieht wieder alles adrett aus die
touristen kommen wieder auf die inseln
vor den toren istanbuls wo auch
gestresste großstädter erholen suchen
und sie essen wieder fisch warum auch
nicht sagt er schaut die tiere sind
kerngesund die kiemen schön rot
wenn die fische von dem stein betroffen
wären würden sie ersticken wenn er in
ihre kiemen gelangt aber das ist nicht
passiert die fischer hatten kein problem
und in diesem jahr gibt es sogar mehr
fische als im vergangenen es gibt jede
menge davon
das gedächtnis der menschen ist kurz und
das ist gut für manager der verbreitet
optimismus alles wieder sauber alles
wieder gut diesen optimismus aber teilen
viele wissenschaftler nicht einer davon
ist musterfassade
meeresbiologe er sagt nur weil man den
schleim nicht mehr sieht ist er noch
lange nicht verschwunden
was wir gesehen haben war gerade mal ein
prozent der gesamtmasse das eigentliche
problem liegt unten auf dem meeresboden
und
dann schreitet der professor zur bade
treppe um der sache auf den grund zu
gehen vor drei monaten hätte er keinen
fuß dorthin gesetzt denn im juni sah die
bucht von er deckt noch so aus der
sogenannte meeres schleim besteht aus
den rückständen winziger alten die
hatten sich in der warmen sommer sonne
rasant vermehrt so stark wie noch nie in
der geschichte
nach wenigen wochen schien der spuk
vorbei oberflächlich betrachtet
professor sari nimmt uns mit in ein
totenreich der größte teil des meeres
schleims ist abgesunken hat sich zu
einer feinen masse zersetzt und erstickt
alles leben unter sich
alle schwämme die in einer tiefe bis 30
meter leben sind tot bei unserem
heutigen tauchgang haben wir nicht einen
einzigen schwamm gesehen da müssten
tausende seien auch die korallen sind
abgestorben in dieser tiefe sind keine
koran mehr zu sehen der schaden ist
riesengroß
grund für die katastrophe meint ari sein
industrie und claire abfälle rund um das
marmarameer befinden sich die größten
industrieanlagen der türkei der wasser
wissenschaftler levent artus beobachtet
seit 30 jahren das langsame sterben des
marmarameeres
artus zeigt uns videos die bereits im
dezember 2020 aufgenommen wurden sie
dokumentieren ein fischsterben in der
nähe der mündung des flusses ärger für
art es besteht ein zusammenhang zwischen
dem fischsterben und dem auftauchen des
meeres schleims rund sechs monate später
damals kannten wir die quelle der
vergiftung noch nichts wir wussten nur
dass es eine zusätzliche schwere
verschmutzung gegeben haben musste
später erfuhren wird das seit dezember
in der nähe des ärgers ist einer der am
stärksten verschmutzten flüsse der welt
schadstoffe durch eine riesige pipeline
in das marmara meer gepumpt werden
diese abwässer vermutetes hätten das
gigantische alben wachstum begünstigt
und die meeres schleim klage ausgelöst
und er fällt ein vernichtendes urteil
das marmarameer kann nicht mehr gerettet
werden es ist tot es ist verschwunden
wir können ab jetzt nur noch verhindern
dass uns das marmarameer schadet dafür
müssen wir unbedingt darauf verzichten
dass mehr als müllhalde zu benutzen und
alles dort hinein zu kippen
aus der müllhalde marmarameer ist immer
weniger essbares zu holen erdal attas
weiß das schon als junge fuhr er mit
seinem vater raus der fischer nimmt uns
mit auf seinem boot will uns die
prinzeninseln vom wasser aus zeigen
wasser das ihn vielleicht nicht mehr
lange ernähren
wer sich der neuen lage anpassen kann
wird weiter existieren
doch wer nur vom fischen lebt der wird
es schwer haben er wird damit sein brot
nicht mehr verdienen können
ich denke darüber nach in den süden zu
gehen ans mittelmeer meint ärger da gibt
es noch sauberes wasser aber vielleicht
wird uns dieser fluch auch dort bald
einholen
es wird noch mehr meeres schleiden geben
davon gehen wir aus vielleicht schon ab
ende oktober wenn das wasser abkühlt es
ist als ob uns das mehr sagen will ich
liege im sterben es ruft rettet mich
oder es wird mit mir zu ende gehen
die türkische regierung hat einen
notfallplan verkündet um die
wasserqualität im marmarameer zu
verbessern doch dafür könnte es
vielleicht schon zu spät sein
[Musik]